in Iraq where at least three people have
died as demonstrators march in a number
of cities across the country to protest
against corruption and a lack of jobs
and services security forces use tear
gas and stun grenades to push protesters
back the protests began hours after
prime minister Adel Abdul mathy
promised to reshuffle his cabinet and
introduce sweeping reforms the police
are active in Massillon happen we plan
to reduce the salaries of officials and
the presidential officers and ministries
as well as members of parliament and
executive managers of national public
entities the funds derived from the
reduction of salaries along with
contributions from the state will be
used to establish a Social Welfare Fund
that ensures that no Iraqi lives below
the poverty line and that any Iraqi
without income will receive a monthly
grant of no less than a hundred and ten
u.s. dollars the Council of Ministers
will submit the draft law to the House
of Representatives for approval a
correspondent Natasha good name is
joining us live from the Iraqi capital
now and as were being reported Natasha
three protesters killed more than a
hundred injured what is the situation
there well we have actually moved to a
side street from Tahrir Square because
the crew decided that had it had just
become too dangerous and once you take a
look know that some of the protesters
who have followed us mostly men in these
protests primarily young and this is the
majority by the way young people are of
the population of Iraq they are out on
the streets protesting as part of a
second wave of protests that began in
October because they're fed up with the
lack of economic opportunities here in
the country they're fed up with the
unreliable basic services such as clean
water and electricity and they say this
government is dysfunctional and corrupt
and they want it out unfortunately based
on yet another round of reforms that the
prime minister adds a lot of the mighty
announced overnight it appears that the
government will not be resigning and
people are telling us that this is
unacceptable one man told us that we
voted for these people we elected these
people and yet we have no dignity now
this is the one year anniversary of
Prime Minister Agha lobner Massey
becoming Prime Minister and I'm sure
it's not quite the milestone he'd hoped
to be marking today he is embattled it's
been a series of reforms announced by
the government it includes slashing the
salaries of the Prime Minister the
president and other top officials in
half and then the hope was to divert the
money to a kind of social welfare
account to help the poor he's announced
an anti-corruption formation
investigation but here's the thing this
anger today is fueled by the fact that
in the first wave of protests in October
149 protesters were killed there were
reports that there were snipers on top
of buildings shooting at protesters the
government and the military are now
acknowledging that excessive force was
used seven commanders were relieved of
their duty their cases are being turned
over to the judiciary and they may face
criminal charges the government is
vowing that those people will be held to
account but again there's a sense among
the people we're talking to today that
we've heard this before
but it's a kind of lip service and what
they really want is a new government
that they hope will finally be
responsive to their needs one man said
it's been 16 years government after
government making empty promises and we
want change and want it now the other
thing that's worth noting is that there
is a real desire for Iraq to be its own
person if you will our own country in
charge of its own destiny people are
angry over what they see as an outside
influence by Iran and the United States
no more foreign meddling
Natacha it is such a delicate situation
now because as you've mentioned the
protests have been inflamed by the fact
that a hundred and fifty protestors have
been killed so far this month so how
does the government go about handling
the current protests we've already heard
of three people killed so far just today
right and about 69 overcome with tear
gas take a look here
what are you min funds like so these are
the tear gas canisters that people are
showing us that
injured people this man was injured I
saw a very disturbing video a short time
ago of a man's head smoking an open
wound from ostensibly one of these tear
gas canisters the day began with the
prime minister saying that people's
right to protest would be respected as
long as quote they did not disrupt
public life as you can see things have
deteriorated people are injured and the
anger is only growing and here's another
thing these protests were not supposed
to start until well after Friday prayers
about 3 p.m. in the afternoon and a new
element in today's protests is that
followers of the Shia cleric moqtada
al-sadr were joining the free to protest
in full force they were actually going
to have what they were calling peace
brigades without weapons to try to
protect protesters so it'll be very
interesting to see in the coming hours
just how many more people come to the
streets but I can tell you that it's
been a tense morning so far and people
are
Natacha are panicking like everybody
another round of teargas
no problem Natasha thank you very much
for there